the lead that you're becoming a
distraction to the SNP by continuing
your membership at the moment when Hamza
yusufas had such a rough couple of
months would it be the best thing for
you to temporarily step back as some of
your colleagues have suggested well
firstly I think Hamza is doing a
fantastic job as fresh Minister
um I when he was elected as first
Minister I expected him to do a good job
I wish he hadn't faced some of the
circumstances he has but I'm incredibly
proud of the job he is doing and I think
he's getting on with that on behalf of
the the people of Scotland
um on the The Wider question you know
what surprise anybody to hear that you
know I search my soul in these questions
on an ongoing basis I have dedicated
most of my life to the SNP and I don't
say that to make it sound like a
sacrifice it's not being a sacrifice the
opportunities and experiences I've had
in return have been immense but the
interests of the SNP are as close as to
my heart as it's possible for anything
to be there may be an argument if I
thought that if I was to step aside that
you would all then accept that this had
nothing to do with the SNP there may be
an argument that's not the case but also
what that would do I think would be to
compromise my ability and my right to
assert the position that I hold
absolutely which is that I have done
nothing wrong but I will always consider
and I'll consider on an ongoing basis at
all times what's in the best interest of
the SNP a party that I have given my all
to over almost my entire life and an
organization that for me is not abstract
it's made up of my friends my family my
colleagues you've heard me describe it
before as my extended family and that's
the depth of love affection and concern
I have for the SMP